let's face it it is impossible to do
justice in 40 minutes
to the incredibly complex and polarizing
country of Israel but I did accomplish
my goal which was to make friends
wherever I went negotiations at a
government level are great but until
people of different backgrounds can
barbecue next to each other in the same
park and their kids can kick the same
soccer ball you will not have peace at a
molecular level then let's remember
we're talking about a country that is
only 69 years old think about it the
u.s. is 240 years old and last time I
checked we still are working out a few
kinks most of all I want to thank the
people of Israel and the West Bank for
their incredible hospitality their humor
and their coffee everywhere I went I was
offered coffee by complete strangers
actually maybe that's the problem
you have several cultures and religions
sharing a very small space and everyone
is amped up on caffeine so maybe at the
end of the day the answer is decaf
[Applause]
[Music]
you